they can start again
yeah we're good to go chair thanks
thank you mr richards if you'd like to
continue
uh thank you jeff um
sorry i
don't know if you can pick up we've got
some road works happening just outside
the building so i hope it's not coming
through
um no we can hear you well okay right
thank you so um
just to where i was so
the music will will not be heard
from the boundaries my client will be
monitoring that
um
that the music will not be um
going beyond the boundary with the
premises
and also anyone vertically drinking
on the streets that is something that is
a a real no-no for him
um it wouldn't be for this premises
and and it currently discourages it now
where he is um
um the building is currently disused
and he wishes to convert it into the
micro pub
to offer the residents in the area and
alternative
premises to sit down and consume
responsibly
consume
quality beers
ciders lagers and some wine
um
i'm not sure how much i like
where i've got to but um
it's coming up so um
i think that's
all is there anything you'd like
[Music]
with the outside drinking that just
won't be a problem because
within our plans there's the outside
drinking within our premises so there
wouldn't be any reason to people go to
the pavement because we'll have them
sort of ashtrays and everything there
something which shouldn't be any litter
going on to play without being
on our premises and if and obviously
i'll sweep and clean every
morning anyway every morning
every morning
so
chair thank you that concludes our
presentation thank you spot fun time
even with a little interlude
um
thank you so if i can go to our um
subcommittee members um counselor mrs
levine shaw would you like to ask some
questions
thank you very much
i'm
looking at the planes on 4.25
it shows you uh you've shown us the type
of furniture you want
how many are you actually going to have
in front of your building
because i is it um because i would like
to know the dimensions because it is
going to be too close to the road and
is that a good ambient way of having a
drink
so the ones directly in front
the front you're building you yeah
you've got two diagrams
um
yeah bench
it's upside down for me be a bench
example and table and chairs example
proposed ground floor plan now these are
the types of tables you're going to have
outside of the front of the building on
looking onto the road
the table and chairs example are
to the back of the building because
there's like a little secret garden
there
and then the tables and chairs will be
like two seaters to the side and then
hopefully we can get some deer benches
just
across the front
but that's not going straight onto the
road obviously the pavement is there
too
it's on our little section
so how many tables and sorry checking
ourselves for supplementary how many
tables and chairs would you like to have
in the front of the building
ideally four
four
okay so that's like a total of eight
people
sitting there
no 16 hopefully we'll get four on the um
benches
right okay
thank you thank you chairman
have you any other questions counselor
mrs shaw um
yeah there is it's condition six um
regarding the front of the premises on
the back um
regarding smoking
i mean it says you can't you're gonna
have the smoking outside but you can't
stop people legally smoking in front of
your building can you so how will you
monitor that with the drinking standing
out there side drinking
i think that's four point two yeah four
point two seven oh sorry um
number six okay um
so
my client will discourage anyone from
being out on the street
from smoking and
you know they'll be regularly regularly
um
looking and
i'm telling the customers that they must
come in so the pavement would not be
used
so you can i just come in there so if
you've got 16 people sitting outside
you've got three people on one of your
benches non-smoke because you've got one
it's a smoker
you're gonna have
say something that they've got to go out
into your secret garden to smoke they
can't sit with their friends and smoke
no sorry 11 o'clock everybody has to
come inside
yeah well i'm just talking about the
daytime anyway just sort of stopping
people smoking outside you're not having
anyone spoken at the front
yeah people can smoke at the front
okay thank you very much no on the
pavement they can't take their drinks
onto the pavement but justine where your
cartilage is yeah oh yeah
okay thank you
thank you
thank you is that your questions
counselor mrs
laurence
yes thank you
um councillor mrs newport your questions
to the apple companies thank you chair i
have a few questions um just going back
on what counselor shaw said with regards
to the table and chairs when you close
up of an evening where are they going
are they staying there and how secure
will they be
the smaller ones the table and chairs
will be taken into the back and then
secured locked away
um
and the benches will hopefully be
locked to chain to the down to the
ground
okay
thank you and then a further question um
with regards to the hot and cold foods
um
how are you going to provide those and
what what are you going to provide
we're going to do little um
toasty sandwiches
so we're going to get the back going to
have like uh one of them sandwich
presses
and um yeah
we went to a little place in tunbridge
wales and it works really well it's a
nice
nice little option and when is that
going to be available from is that going
to be all throughout your opening hours
um probably till nine
until nine
okay thank you
and then i do have another couple of
questions if i may
with regards to the cctv provision you
have it within the property within the
building
are you anticipating having any cctv on
the outside as that is where
mainly your your customers are going to
be yeah i definitely am actually i'm
supposed to start on the planets but
i'll definitely have a
camera pointing
everywhere yeah
to to assist with that what we can do we
can uh we're happy to liaise with the
licensing police
and get some guidance on what they're
happy with as well
so um so the whole premise is inside and
outside
without
without
any privacy beyond the the cartridge of
of the premises
yeah so you you anticipate having the
cctv outside yeah
and then one last one if i may um with
regards to dorman
um do you think that it would be
advisable to have dorman on a friday and
saturday evening as most of the other
licensed premises within rayleigh doe
for safety
um
it's something that we will consider and
what we'll do we'll also do it on a
risk basis needs so
obviously because
this isn't this is a new premises
um it's
quite hard to gauge what is going to be
required but we will do it on a risk
based
um basis
and then if need be then it would be in
place
so on your risk assessment basis how are
you going to do that can i just ask that
i've actually got a dps licence myself
so i can um
certainly look into it a bit when um we
put in the application the police
haven't requested
um
dorman
um but
sadly
you know the security of my guests
and staff be paramount um
[Music]
but
at the moment we just think it's just
too small amount of people
to want
your stuff at the moment
right okay and then just for my own um
nosiness really what what what um
alcohol do you want to sell is it just
craft beers or is it wine as well as
spirits and fizzy bubbles alcopops
it won't be alcopops it's so it's um
it'll be nice wines that we have it's
like artisanal natural wines
um and then spirits but it's not sort of
stuff that you see it's not like
smelling often gordon's it's um it'll
all be sort of hand-picked
sort of
artisanal but gin but spirits like gin
a small selection yeah
okay thank you that's all my questions
thank you thank you
thank you
um
right i've got a few questions please um
first of all on a page 4.11
um you're asking um within your
application the extension for the music
on the friday and saturday night to
midnight
um now bearing in mind you will be
closing at midnight
and just the
prevention of the public nuisance of the
noises people are leaving your premises
would you consider
reducing that to say 11 30
giving a half hour quiet time while
you're still open
as people are possibly leaving your
premises so they don't hear them
neighbours don't hear the new music in
and out yeah that's fine um so it's like
it won't really ever be any live music
isn't too small but so just be
background music so i'm quite happy to
turn it all down turn the lights up and
turn the music down
thank you
um
so um you'll be quite happy if that was
um reduced to 11 30 p.m yeah
yes thank you um
you heard me obviously ask the licensing
officer about pub watch
now if i can refer to page 4.17
on the agenda around the licensing
objectives
would you consider joining pub watch
and also agreeing with their principle
of when one person is banned from one
establishment in rayleigh they're banned
from all
yes i would um
when uh we were i've been to pub watch
meetings before actually because i
worked for the green king pub company
and all their pubs signed up to it and i
definitely believe in the uh bulk steam
because it's just better for everybody
so i think it would be stupid for anyone
not to be in it
definitely
yeah
everything really yeah sure uh my client
would also be willing to sign up to it
in the radio link
um
scheme toward the town center so
you can be informed and inform the
surrounding areas
lovely thank you very much um
now um
you're
taking your clientele into your premises
from 9 pm
um a further request because um that
that
is
good for the residents because as you
know even just people outside can add to
the noise
that they're going to be hearing um
would you consider that your off sales
license is reduced
to 9 pm
that will just help with people who may
be turning out coming in buying going
leaving shutting the doors opening the
doors and the noise again
and the impact on public nuisance
for the surrounding residents
chair um
that is something that we would consider
um however i i
believe that to
agree that now could be quite
detrimental
um to give an example if
a couple
if a couple comes in to the premises
uh has a uh
this like snack
and or there's a bottle of wine and then
decides to take it home at 9 30
and consume it at home by having that
condition
that would
very much uh be detrimental to
to to the
operation um
what i would probably offer up as a
condition
is possibly
um no off cells
will be
will be provided to anybody just walking
off the street
to come in to purchase
after a certain time after a certain
time
thank you
uh i don't know if that will
will survive so
to clarify
at a certain time
at your discretion
that
nobody will just come in to purchase
a
bottle of alcohol or alcohol and support
off sales purchase
thank you um
now if i can refer to
4.27 on the agenda and bear with me i'm
just going to turn myself down to there
myself so
i can see what i've highlighted
um
point four um notices will be displayed
close to the entrance exit
um doors to the premises reminding
patrons of the residential area nearby
and asking patrons to leave the premises
quietly
and we know
a lot of landlords will do that how will
you enforce that to reduce the public
nuisance element
[Music]
um
the premises
is quite small
um so
there will probably be a member of staff
probably outside most of the time in all
time
and
you know within the briefing of staff
and mr reynolds himself will be will be
ensuring
that the patrons outside of the building
will not
be
adding to any nuisance
um
and it will be just for the normal
everyday every minute
monitoring and and advising and stopping
people
from from doing so
if it was one of their clients and if it
continued
then
very much so we did say you know
they will be banned from the premises if
that is the problem
thank you
um and uh on the same page actually um
0.9
um which covers no waste recycling
materials including bottles shall be
moved removed
or placed in or outside areas between 2
100 hours and
8 a.m
the following day
i'm asking if a consideration could be
given for sundays
to change the 8 a.m on sundays to 9 30
a.m
oh yeah uh we won't be opening until 12
anyway so
yeah we can move that until like 11.
that's fine right no one's going to be
there at 8 o'clock
thank you
um and i
think i'm nearly there i've also got one
um
what is your provision for deliveries um
due to the proximity of the zebra
crossing in relation to public safety
so
what we'd we get very small deliveries
because we're not a uh big pub we don't
get sort of big trailers or anything get
smaller so amazon stuff so it's it's
going to be from that has to be from the
high street and then barrow ground
unfortunately you can't park outside of
ours there's absolutely no way because
it's um
it's double your license zigzags so it
has to have to be brought down from the
high street
my only concern is how are you going to
convey that to mr amazon who will park
wherever mr amazon wants to park well no
it won't be actually from amazon it will
be from uh from uh wholesalers and
they'll be told
but give you have to give them
directions of where where to make the
deliveries but they come from sort of
breweries and they they do uh yeah so
chair just to recap that the the
breweries
um suppliers that mr reynolds will be
using they will be given clear
instructions
of of um
where they should park and it will be
their high street
and
you know and they will be forewarned
that it is a bit of a
distance yeah right yeah
okay thank you very much uh mr reynolds
and mr richards
um our licensing officer do you have any
questions for the applicant
no thank you
thank you our interested parties
um have you got questions for the
applicant please
um
not if i get to say something later on
is that right
and how this works
yes yes it is but if you would like to
ask any questions you're invited to now
okay um i believe that the
um
the beer garden is going to be open
until
11 o'clock at night is that right
uh that that's correct yes
so it's not nine o'clock it's it's 11
o'clock at night
that is correct okay
thank you um any further questions no no
thank you very much
um we now move on um
officers the there is nobody from um the
police or anybody here is that
nice correct yeah yeah
thank you um so now we move back back to
you um as our interested um uh party uh
mr brown isn't it um you've got a 15
minutes yourself now um
to um speed
okay well um
i've got two main concerns which are
safety and noise um the site is directly
opposite the crown's beer garden
and with premises on both sides of the
road and the narrow pavements it will be
hard for passersby to avoid the drunk
people who concrete outside those
premises and drunk people can be very
intimidating
um
although the applicant says they'll try
and stop customs going outside of the
beer garden the plans show there are 54
seats outside and the beer garden is
right next to the pavement only
separated by a low fence
um so they won't be able to stop drunk
passers-by from stopping there if they
see their friends
um or enemies and um
nor will they be able to influence
people who have left their premises
and have decided to just stop there
um i know they want to sell craft beer
um but i think i'm right in saying the
licenses for alcohol in general
so
if it turns out that the
um
drinkers of raleigh are resistant to
craft beers
then they might find themselves needing
to
change what they're selling
um
and move to different types of alcohol
which sell better
[Music]
and as i understand it the other license
allows for that
[Music]
so there are other people who are using
the town in the evenings and um
with their dining coming home from work
or evening clubs and they shouldn't have
to run the gauntlet of drunkenness
between two premises
um secondly i'm concerned about noise
generated by the premises and its
customers um
although the applicant says they'll
close the doors
um after nine o'clock eighty percent of
the seating is outside so i'm not sure
that's gonna make much difference
um there's going to be people
constantly going in and out to get
drinks
and if if that's full then the noise of
54 people is going to be heard
in in you know all the way down the
street and it's going to go until 11
o'clock at night
um
[Music]
and
those those are my concerns the um
i think the representation from other
residents which i hope the community
have read make it clear what it's like
at the moment
um if if i can read just a couple of
things from mrs lawrence's statement
which is
uh
4.41
um chair can i just come in there i
don't think we would want to be hearing
other residents ever written evidence
from
from this applicant yeah because it's
not their direct evidence and obviously
members will be advised in due course
about how much weight to give to the
written representation i don't think
that's um something that we want to do
at this stage yeah i think you agree
yeah yeah no i do agree officer um mr
brown i hope you appreciate that because
i can assure you that we have already
read through all these papers and the
submissions um but take your time is
there anything else you want to
include
just to finish up um if you've if you
read those representations you'll know
um the severe disturbance that people on
the street are already experiencing
and um
which is caused by the drinking
apprentices in the town and the drunken
behaviour they generate and i hope um
you'll listen to nearby families who
don't want another pub so close to their
homes
um thank you
thank you
um now uh members of the subcommittee
you can ask further questions of the
applicant but only for clarification
is there anything that you would like to
ask
no i think all
my questions were answered chair thank
you
uh council mrs jupiter
yeah if i may um the boundary is is
there going to be any fencing or is it
just the low fencing and little bits of
shrubbery or is there going to be
something to withstand the clients
within that boundary
sure just to
come in there so these questions are
just for the interested party at this
stage i just checked is that question
for for them
my apologies um
to our officer i'm literally reading the
agenda and it says
of the applicant so you know just wanted
to check if council newport's question
is for the interested party or could it
sound like it was for the atmosphere
yeah my apology essentially
we just checked
now for the applicant
could they just clarify
could they just clarify whether that's
on the plan there's little green
shrubbery is there fencing low level
fencing or is it just
decorative shrubbery is it to keep the
clients within their boundary
to stop them is just stepping over it
sure i think what i think what we need
to do is just finish the evidence of the
interested party and then if there is
any further questions that members have
within your gift to go back to
reconsider at the moment we're just
dealing with the interested party
submissions
yep um
[Music]
so we just need to check if anyone has
any questions for the interested parties
and once we've had all those questions
we can then go back if council newborn
has a question for the applicant
okay if you have a look at the agenda
later it just says applicant not
interested party so
my apologies commit um subcommittee
members um
have you any questions counseling this
is lorraine shaw for now i haven't any
from any questions for the interested
parties thank you yeah
councilman
no questions for the interested parties
thank you do the applicants have any
questions for the interested party
uh sorry no chair
don't have any questions
thank you our licensing officer do you
have any questions
no thank you
thank you
um
so chris just to
um be certain this is where our
subcommittee members can now ask the
applicant if they need anything
clarified yeah i mean the the questions
have already been asked um for the
applicant they've already given their
evidence but if you feel chair that
there is something that you need to go
back and then it's within your um
you know your gift to go back i think
counter newport does have a question so
if if you're in agreement then there's
no issues with that
i i am and i've got one question for
clarification as well okay thank you
councillor mrs newport please ask that
question again of the applicant thank
you
thank you chair um
the boundary is that little bushes
little shrubbery low fencing
what level of
fencing or
to maintain the clients within your
boundary what is that could you just
clarify that please yeah so it's
actually it's going to be about four
foot high actually there's going to be
like black metal bars that go around
wooden things it's kind of nice and it
sort of just yeah it like pins people in
going for the top
round so you've got you can't step over
it or anything like anywhere you will be
an enclosed area okay thank you
thank you
um
i've got a question for clarification
for um the applicant
um
when counsellor mrs laurene shaw asked
the question about the benches up front
um you clearly stated that they're for
non-vertical drinking so for people who
are sitting down
was that correct
and if so are people allowed to stand in
there that could then unfortunately trip
or fall
um into the walkway
um so
they're after sitting but but that fence
i just mentioned will be in front of it
so they won't
that you can't wouldn't be able to fall
sort of into the pavement
area
um
but you you can't you could stash that
strip
so people can still stand out the front
and there could be the possibility that
they could stumble out into the pavement
no not out onto the pavement because
that that fought the aforementioned
fence would be there
it's been quite high and that's in front
of it
and the fence goes right across there's
no walkway in
so the walkways are
both sides
and then and there's no chairs
sort of that close to the walkways the
walkways always be
clear
okay
thank you for answering um
it with me i'm just going back up to my
agenda
okay um
so we're coming to closing statements um
any party is permitted to make a short
closing statement not exceeding two
minutes in the order of the closing
statements will be first of all the
applicant would you like to make a
closing statement
yeah yeah
um so
the closing statement never made closing
statements have been with me a little
bit um so
for a closing statement i'm completely
happy to work alongside the police and
the ehr to maintain a quality
sort of establishment
a lot of the questions come from
drunkenness and spilling out afterwards
but i agree with the statement that
it's legal to sell alcohol to someone
who's intoxicated and i'd uphold that
law so i wouldn't it's such a small
place i wouldn't envision sort of having
the
um
that sort of
public nuisance
um yeah i would like to just
maintain a quality place that i've got
myself sort of i've got the five star
hygiene weight in and stuff and so
that's what i'd like to bring to
rayleigh and really create something
that really would be proud of um so
obviously there's a lot of negativity
but about this application but i would
like to it be seen as a positive thing i
mean being jobs to rayleigh and it'll be
something really nice something really
nice from top of the hill really good
you know there is there is a lot of
concern but again liaising with the
police
and the environmental health
uh to a point where they've agreed
conditions and they haven't submitted
any objections or representation
and therefore if
they support
uh we can only say that we support
um
with the conditions that we have
we have supplied and agreed to
thank you
thank you that is your two minutes thank
you very much
thank you um our licensing officer for
you bernie
close entertainment
uh no thank you
thank you
and our interested party uh mr brown
have you any closing statement
only to reiterate what i've said already
that the residents are fed up with
drunkenness um the noise in
the broken glass and litter
and the safety
in
in the town and um
there is severe disturbance at night and
we and we hope
that there won't be another pub so close
to our homes thank you thank you thank
you
all right um
so ladies and gentlemen uh the committee
will now adjourn to consider the case we
will return approximately
um our officers could advise on that i
would say
an hour
yet whatever you kind of feel you need
chair and members and i think that
sounds probably as most we would need i
think that's members
uh committee members are you happy with
an hour's agenda thank you
um to announce the decision this will
also be sent to you in writing you do
not have to wait but you are welcome to
do so
yeah and chair obviously if we are back
a lot longer shorter period then we will
um contact the parties and see if they
can come back earlier on call so no
one's waiting around unnecessarily
thank you very much thank you
okay